So
hello, we are
here today to hear about earthquakes.
Earthquakes occur in nature. They are
very, very bad. Earthquakes also occur
in the laboratory. I have two experts
with me who will tell us something about it. My
name is Josef Zenz. I come from the
German Georesearch Center  In
Potzdam we research, among other things,
earthquakes and volcanoes
but also
geothermal energy, deep boreholes,
tsunamis, we research all possible processes in the
solid earth at the German
georesearch center
and I have two
scientists here next to me:
Carolin Böse dr Carolin Böse who is the
lead scientist on a
project that is  georeal will
then tell you something about it
and on the other side is Marco
Bonhoff, who is a professor and heads
a section that is like a
department here where the
researchers organize themselves into
different departments and the
section is called geomechanics and
scientific drilling, yes that  There are
a lot of bad words, the
worst of which I have with you:
cross-scale deformation processes.
That's really crazy. You'll have to
explain later what that means.
I, Marco, has been at the GFZ for 20 years.
GFZ is the abbreviation for
georesearch center
You can see that it was done and he started
with us as a scientific worker
and had previously studied geophysics in
Hamburg and, um, I
asked you how that came about. I see a
whole bunch of children and
the parents are probably there too, so when they have
theirs  Want to get children
to study geophysics, what do they have to
do? Have a good atlas on the table. Have a
children's atlas on the table. So
as a little boy, they looked at the children's atlas
and thought, I want to know what's
going on.
Now he's a geophysicist here and he's the
director of the
ICDP  again something
complicated
intercontinental
deep yes deepb prramm ne drilling no only
without deep
intercontinental drilling program
icdp he can also
tell you something about it and you Carol you were in
New Zealand for 10 years I also learned there are
also Alps in New Zealand so they are
n't just here  but when the
Europeans came to New Zealand and
the mountains were GT oh great, it looks
like the Alps, they're just called the
Southern Alps
and what's happening now
the two of them talk for
about fifteen minutes and then we can
ask questions if you have any questions
because they don't understand something or they're
just waving something, then
we can sort it out in the meantime
if any of the words are too complicated,
cross-scale
deformation processes are
still missing, I won't do it much longer Marco
starts Karolin will then take over
and then we'll do a bit of an interview
question answer okay  All clear,
thank you very much
Josef while I'm waiting for the slides
or do I have to do something here? Yes, we
brought a lot with us, a
lot of information because the topic
is a big one and a complicated one.
We'll try to break it down a bit
and focus on some aspects
illuminate earthquakes
when you hear the word earthquake what do
you think of disasters broken houses
dead people
m but our goal is
to understand these processes in order to ultimately
avoid damage at some point and how we will
do that
Carolin and I will do that in the next
half hour or so  try
to explain why what is it about why do
earthquakes even exist what are
earthquakes and why do they pose a
risk what do we know today about the
processes can you control earthquakes
next question can you
predict earthquakes who knows what is the
answer to that no no you know too
Well, why not let's see, maybe we
'll know in half an hour, I'll ask
again later, so let's start
very early. In ancient times there were
always earthquakes, but in the past there were no
big cities, no
infrastructure, which is why the earthquakes
usually didn't cause much damage  Of
course, people have
always asked the question why do
earthquakes exist, what's
behind them, and in the past the answer was
usually earthquakes are a punishment from
God, given by nature, that's always
the easiest answer if you
can't explain it, and yes you could  I ca
n't explain it either. In
Greece, for example, there used to be a theory that the
continents float and wobble on the sea
and when they rock,
the earth wobbles and then there are
earthquakes. There was also the
idea back then that earthquakes erupt from caves
and that's quite interesting
Because there is actually something like that,
today we call it coal fires, smoldering fires, which
occur in various places in the world
where there is underground fire and
raging and uh, that could also be explained back then, so
it was
linked to earthquakes,
uh, in the Middle Ages it was still there
The natural disasters are actually
attributed to the work of God, for example in
Lisbon in 1755, I think there was a very
strong earthquake, all the saints when the
people were in church and it
stands to reason that this was then
understood as a punishment from God, there are
a number of them  from philosophical
works and so on,
as a short warm-up, we are
much further along today. About 100 years ago,
someone Alfred Wegener came onto the stage
and said no, no,
you can understand that, there is a
system behind how the continents
move  They get caught relative to each other
and this causes earthquakes.
Alfred Wegner presented this at a conference
in Frankfurt and was expelled from the
room.
It was laughed at and was not pursued further for decades
until later after
Alfred Wegener died on a
polar expedition
Unfortunately, he was no longer alive and
his theory of
plate tectonics was
confirmed through new measuring methods and so on.
So where are there earthquakes? We know
exactly that. 90% of earthquakes take place
along plate edges, i.e.
where the earth's plates meet each other
push past and get caught then
then energy builds up and when
is the strength of the G stone
exceeded and then it tears and then
an earthquake occurs all the areas that
are red here are zones of earthquakes
and I won't go through all of them now
maybe they have and  You've
ever heard of the circum Pacific
Ring of Fire, which is basically the
entire area around the Pacific Ocean
where there are always strong earthquakes
or the area I don't have a pointer here right now
along the Alps and Anatolia
still plays a role and up to  In
the Himalayas, we know relatively well
where they occur, not everywhere. 10%
of earthquakes do not occur at these
plate boundaries, which is a
bit of a problem because we ca
n't say where the second point is, how
strong an earthquake it will be  a
bit more difficult and the
most difficult question is when will an
earthquake occur and we
actually can't say that in advance today
we would like to say the day after tomorrow 7
a.m. earthquake magnitude 7 in Cologne in
Istanbul somewhere you have to evacuate the city
we can't do that today
and  We probably won't be able to do that
in the foreseeable future, but our goal
at some point is to get far enough to
understand the processes so that we
can do it after all. Let's take a look at
Germany, I'd say it looks a
little better in Germany
Not that many
earthquakes at all and what is shown here
are, on the one hand, many white dots, these
are all earthquakes that have occurred
in Germany in the last several hundred years,
but they are not so big
that entire cities
are destroyed, but rather they shake
sometimes a glass shakes in the cupboard, there's
maybe a crack in the house and
sometimes very rarely it gets a
little stronger but it's not not a
big problem so where are we we're
here in Berlin we're safe so
100% 100% have  We're never actually in
science, so we ca
n't say 100% that there will
never be an earthquake in Berlin, but
we're already over 99% somewhere in
that direction, so it's very, very
unlikely that an
earthquake will ever occur here, which is also noticeable  what
takes place in Berlin you can
feel earthquakes in Berlin from time to time, these are
earthquakes that occur in Poland in the copper
mining industry with a magnitude of 3
to 4. I'll explain what that means in a
moment, you can then see the high
floors in high-rise buildings in Berlin
when it happens  If it's early in the morning and it's very quiet,
you can notice a bit of shaking,
but that's nothing serious.
Interestingly, there are also a
few big earthquakes in Germany and
these are so-called induced earthquakes
or man-made earthquakes.
My colleague Carolina will have something to
say about that  e.g. earthquakes that
occur in coal mining when you
pull out large amounts of coal and rock from below, you relieve the pressure on the rock
and then earthquakes usually have a
magnitude of 23, so it's not that bad.
Salt mining, um there are
earthquakes in
natural gas production in northern Germany, the
yellow dots that hang  Together with
gas production and there are quite a few
earthquakes, these red dots are
connected to geothermal energy and therefore they play
a larger
role, so let's go into a little more
detail, a bit of quantitative research.
You all probably know the
Richter scale from the
earthquake news  We all know magnitude 5 on the
Richter scale, which is open at the top, from
the Tagessau
Push two earth's plates past each other and such an earthquake is
not like the point just drawn, that is
a simplification, but during an
earthquake, plates and
sometimes very large plates move by several
meters and we then calculate the
energy from this and that is then shown on the
Richter scale  Do
n't go into too much detail now, but this
is a logarithmic scale, which means that
if we
go from 3 to 4 then
we have one more magnitude but we have
30 times as much energy and if we go two
levels further then we don't have
30 + 30  Times as much energy but 30 x
30 so 900 and you can break that up to
900 30,000 and so on, which means there
is a huge range of energy
and we start at the top
with magnitudes 7 to 9, so they are
earthquakes that
are ready to be seen on a daily basis  where a lot is happening,
we have
earth plates several hundred kilometers long and 10 to
20 km thick that are pushing past each other by several meters
and this is
now a fake, this is not a photo
but this is a reconstruction of the
earthquake near Sumatra that is on
the sea floor  Along 1000 km from the
seabed to a depth of 50 km the plates
shifted by an average of 10 m, so a
huge earthquake like that and now I'll come
back to the top what does that
actually mean that doesn't mean that earthquakes
can be infinitely large
9 9.4 is  pretty much the largest
earthquake you can imagine that can
happen on earth.
Furthermore, it makes no physical sense.
An earthquake of magnitude 10 would
mean that we have an S Andreas
fault that extends around the earth
and shifts in one jerk
We don't have that there isn't
Magnitude 11 would mean that the
entire earth breaks into two parts just in terms
of energy and that is
at the same time the energy that the earth
receives every day every year in the form of solar energy so everything is
energy but the top is open  doesn't make
that much sense now we go in the
other direction towards the smaller
earthquakes, which is
a salt mine salt mining where
earthquakes occur every now and then we
then have smaller fracture surfaces and when we
have magnitudes of -1 -2 that
can happen  You can't
feel it anymore, but we can measure it and that's
why it's important that we can measure it
because from that we can understand
what's happening. There are
two plates, two rock plateaus
that are about a few
square meters in size, that
shift  Then by a few millimeters
and then it gets even smaller. We bring
the earthquakes into the laboratory and
create our own earthquakes. I'll get another
piece of stone so
I can show it quite well, as
shown below. We squeeze
the rocks so hard  until they break at some point
and that creates very small
earthquakes and Carolin will tell you more about that in a moment,
so I come back to the
question of why can you
predict earthquakes? When we are in
public
the question always comes up: you have been researching for so long  Why ca
n't you now
finally predict earthquakes? It ca
n't be that difficult. An analogue what we
bring is compared to the
weather forecast because it works there,
you can predict the weather well,
not 100% but let's say 90
plus%.  Then the information is
90% 70 10% tomorrow it will rain so
we have a complete view of the
system we have all the mathematical
formulas we need and we can
then deduce from them how the weather is
developing earthquakes happen kilometers
beneath our feet 10  km 20 km and
we can't get there, the only
way to get there is drilling
and drilling are very, very expensive and
very, very complicated, you can
compare it with space research when
you shoot a satellite into space and
then you basically have a sensor on
a cable  the cable is broken,
everything is gone and it's the same
with
the drilling, so I didn't want to go any
further because I brought Malin's picture from
Turkey here. I'll come
back to it in a moment, just to make it
clear what it means if we have
an earthquake before  If we wanted to say, then
we would have to be
underground on huge areas here
as an example 200 km x 20 km, we have to
know on every square meter what kind of
rock is there, how much tension
is there and how much tension can
this piece of rock withstand, that is,
example Turkey there  The area is 200
km long and 20 km deep. That's 4 billion
measuring points that we need. That's 4
billion drillings and it quickly becomes
clear why that's so difficult and
why we're not yet very far
ahead of predicting earthquakes.
I think I'll skip this
I'm a bit too
far back in time, of course we have
models
of what happens underground and the
problem with earthquakes is simply that
they no longer just happen like they did for
thousands of years,
but that today we have large
population centers along active
tectonic plate edges and
That's a video from Turkey in
February there was a very
strong earthquake in Turkey with almost 60,000 deaths and
that's the result and that's why
we say earthquakes don't K people
buildings the problem is
buildings that aren't earthquake-proof, that's it
the actual risk that
needs to be managed in the short term, regardless
of the fact that we are of course trying to be able to
predict earthquakes at some point
and how do we do it? There are
three approaches, one is simulation,
i.e. computer models, that is
not the focus of what we are doing
in Potzdam today  We do
laboratory experiments, which means we bring
the earth into the laboratory and can then
control all the conditions and
crush rocks and we do
field measurements and use
drilling for this and Josef has already mentioned that
in Potzdam we have been coordinating
the global
research land drilling program
ICDP for 27 years now  From the icdp we drill for
very different purposes, we
drill into old sediments to
see what the climate used to be like, we
drill into volcanoes to
conduct geothermal energy research, we
drill into old, very old cratons in
South Africa, 3 billion year old crust
where we can reconstruct how
The continents have developed and we
drill into active plate edges to
research earthquakes and this is an
overview of the
key projects that are running on the topic
and I want to show a few pictures.
A lighthouse project for drilling for
earthquakes I say is the SAF
Project where the St Andreas
fault was drilled into the fault halfway between
San Francisco and Los Angeles,
so this
is the S Andreas fault zone and
this is the hole that was first
drilled next to it in order to be able to measure better
and then the hole was deflected
and drilled through the fault
into the earthquake zone to
see what was happening where the earthquakes
occur and there were a number of
very spectacular measurement results. One,
for example, was measured with a 40 finger caliber, that
is, it is a
measuring device that you can then use
Push the hole in to the point where the
earthquakes happen and this shows the
measurement, that is, this measurement shows
that the hole is shifting because
the earth's plates
are not caught at this point but they are crawling
past each other very slowly and that
's good because then it collects  There is no
energy and then the energy is immediately
dissipated and no one notices it but there
are other areas where things
are messy where energy builds up and then
in a flash
the energy is released in a battle during an earthquake.
A second project where we are also
active  In India there
is a huge dam that
fills up every time the monsoon rain starts,
then the water level rises and because there
is a lot of water on top in
this dam, the pressure increases
and then earthquakes occur under the dam,
these curves show  the
water level curve of different
years and that is the earthquake curve.
Whenever the water level rises there are
earthquakes, so it is a perfect place
to research earthquakes and
the preparation is now underway and drilling 7 km
deep into this earthquake zone in order to
then measure directly when the
water level rises  rises what is happening now
and then you can measure earthquakes in a few
meters distance in the best case scenario
yes the third example we go
back to Turkey is Istanbul
Istanbul is one or the hotspot in
terms of earthquake risk at least
in Europe the map is relatively easy
to read  Seismic hazard map
of Turkey Everywhere where it is red,
earthquakes occur and these are large
areas of Turkey. The earthquake in February took
place here, so we knew
that there was a high risk there,
but it is still very
difficult to protect cities with over a million inhabitants from earthquakes
and the next hotspot, as
we know there is agreement in the
expert world, will be Istanbul. Istanbul
today has 16 or 17 million inhabitants
and is located right next to a fault
next to an active plate boundary where the
earth's plates are like that and that's
what lies behind the pile  now
measured from GPS measurements with satellites,
that means you can see how the
earth's plates are shifting, Turkey
is shifting to the west relative to
Eurasia, it is moving south
here we have the Arabian plate
komop upwards, we have understood everything well
and the movement is happening
along  This red line in the
last 100 years we have had a
sequence of strong earthquakes that is unique in the world, these
are the
annual numbers, these are all earthquakes of
magnitude 7 or larger and you can see
how the earthquakes are moving towards the west on a string of pearls,
the entire
plate boundary is already there  has been relieved
in the last 100 years except for the
area in front of Istanbul the red area
this is the part of the
plate boundary that will produce the next earthquake
and the scenarios for this
are not good due to the proximity of this
plate boundary to Istanbul we know
quite a lot about  the history because there is
a long
history of settlement there over 2000 years,
we can reconstruct when there
was a strong earthquake there and we know that
on average a large earthquake occurs there every 250 years
so now let's see
when was the last one
1766 1766 + 250 we are already
But the earthquakes don't happen exactly
every 250 years, but 250 years plus -
50, that means it can happen tomorrow, it
can happen in 10 years or in 50
years, we don't know that, but the
risk is high and we can
now quantify it all  I do
n't want to go into it in detail now,
I've already mentioned the scenarios,
so it's
expected that there will be more than 50,000
fatalities and more than 500,000
homeless people in the event of the earthquake and,
as I said, it's not a question of if,
but only of
when so that's the that's the
risk map that shows where in Europe the
risk is big. Risk doesn't mean
that earthquakes occur there, but
these red areas are called that's where
earthquakes occur and there is
infrastructure there, i.e. big cities,
industrial plants and so on and there
is  very clearly visible Istanbul is in the
darkest red, of course Italy
Greece Turkey is overall at a very
high risk but um our research
focuses on
Istanbul
for various reasons and we
started building an observatory there about 15 16 years ago
in order to be
as close as possible to this
fault zone
um to measure what's happening there before
a big earthquake and then at
some point during and
after and I'll click
through a bit now, we're happy to go into more detail about it,
we've sunk a hole in order to
insert our seismometers and the microphones deep into the earth because
It's quieter there, we can listen better there
and we can also measure a lot of small
earthquakes because the smaller earthquakes
are, the more frequently they occur, so that
always means that the researchers don't
just sit at the desk and
work on the computer, it also means
Field work and that's not always nice
but it's also part of it. It's also good to
know where the data comes from because
generating good measurement data is always
complicated and this is what a drilling looks like.
Our drilling is 300 m
deep and these are our microphones
Seismometers that we put into the hole
and then we can monitor
the seismity there using various measuring methods.
This is what these
measuring devices look like
and there is a container on the surface
and the data is
published on the Internet and sent directly to
Ankara to our colleagues from the
Turkish civil protection and  to us
in Potzdam where we then evaluate them
scientifically.
We are now a good
deal further ahead than we were 17 years ago because
through this measurement we can
measure processes that we cannot otherwise measure,
almost like in the laboratory, and from this
we can then call it a fever curve
namely, we can, so to speak,
very carefully, we are in the process of
understanding what is happening underground
and whether the danger is now getting a little
bigger and a little smaller
and here we have measured an earthquake
that has a magnitude of 4, so it is
not wild but occurs more often  because we do
n't have time to wait 100 years until
the next big event and we see
a precursor phenomenon, i.e. a
preparatory process underground that
tells us that something
could happen right away and if that
can be measured systematically then
that would take us a big step
forward  Maybe then to be able to
warn the population because what
is crucial is to be able to say in the minutes and
hours before an earthquake,
okay, something could happen,
leave your houses, you ca
n't do that too often because if you
do it five times and nothing happens
then  people don't go out anymore and
then
the sensitivity decreases and that
's bad for
warning so now I don't know how I'm
in time, I still have a few
minutes left,
well that's the level of knowledge that
we know today and that's a lot  I
had already shown the area that
will produce the next earthquake
is about 200 km long from here to here.
With our measurement we can
now see which areas the
earth or the earth's plates are
creeping past each other - these are the blue
areas and where they are completely
These are the red areas and
when they are damaged,
energy accumulates and then these are the
problem areas because a lot of energy is
stored there and as you can see, unfortunately
the area immediately south of the
Istanbul gate is completely red, which means that is
where they are  Both plates are completely
screwed, the plates push, push,
push, the earth is screwed
and at some point the strength of the
rock is exceeded and
all the energy of 250 or more years
is released within seconds,
but we can derive even more from this
because we can and we know
Modeling and also from
laboratory experiments that in the areas
where the earth or where the rocks
creep a little, there
is a high probability that
an earthquake will start there. An earthquake is
not a jagged one, but rather a large
area and it starts somewhere
Crack and it spreads and from this
we can then calculate scenarios in
which direction the waves are
spreading and with this we can
calculate the ground vibration and
then say very locally that these city towns
are more at risk than others and
that is then again important to get the
disaster relief officers quickly  to bring it to the place
where the greatest
damage
occurred. We are currently continuing to drill. We have
just
received approval for a large research project, which
now allows us
to sink a new borehole. Our previous boreholes are
concentrated in the area in front of
Istanbul and we will now do so in January
drilling on this peninsula here and
here so that we can then enclose the entire area
and then monitor the entire
area with better
accuracy, yes, and
with that I first
tried to explain the big, bad earthquakes,
now we're going a little bit there,
we can actually control earthquakes
and  Carolin Bö will now take over this
and
will bring them back to Germany,
namely to the KTB, which is a research infrastructure that is
unique in the world. There
are two
deep boreholes where we are now
doing very interesting interesting things,
please Kolin, thank you very much, yes exactly, so
we have at the moment right now  There's a
big project going on here at this
location that you can see here, it
's a big bohurm that was
set up there 30 years ago because they
drilled an incredible kilometer deep here 30 years ago, that's as
deep as the planes fly up, so
when you start  looks at the sky and sets such
a small plane that's how deep we
drilled there and that was an
incredible undertaking that took many
years to get there and
you would actually have liked to
drill even deeper but at 9 km it was
so warm that  Practically the drill bits
could no longer work properly, so you couldn't
continue drilling as quickly as you had
planned and then it just was
n't worth it anymore, exactly and
I'll come back to this project at the
end, why we're doing it and
now I want to talk a little bit about it
Why do we do this? So we
want to understand processes and here
I have
listed for you what
an earthquake looks like when we
record it and here at the top
everyone has probably heard that the
2011 Tohoku earthquake happened in Japan
A lot of things were broken, it was a
huge earthquake and it was a
magnitude nine, practically the
biggest thing we've seen so far and
down here I showed an example
of a goldmine in South Africa
and that was a magnitude -3
very, very small quake but you can see that
they are very similar in
appearance and here are a
few other examples below, here a
magnitude 4 from a geothermal field in
South America and here a magnitude -8
that is incredibly small, I'll show you
how small it is  but again they
look very similar and here below is
a third example from one of
these copper mines in Poland and also
from the gold mine
and that is exactly this. We look at
the data we get on
different scales and try to use
it  to learn a scale for the next
scale and right now I have here
again just as a reminder
so magnitude -8 tiny small a
grain of sand falls down a centimeter in such an
hourglass that is the energy that
is released in such a tiny earthquake and  We no longer call that an
earthquake because it is so small that there is
no earth there BBT. We call that
acoustic emission because you
can possibly hear it, so magnitude
-3 means a cell phone falls off the table
or a truck drives right
past you, that is  So the
energy that is released here,
magnitude zero is still pretty small
when a whole team of I do
n't know 15 people runs into a wall
and the wall shakes, that's a
magnitude zero and then
the biggest earthquakes that are caused by
humans, so to speak
because humans are
interfering with the subsoil and this
may
lead to the closure of a mine,
which is magnitude 4 and the
very small ones we measure in the laboratory, these are
the induced seismicity, i.e. the ones
caused by humans  we
in the mine or also for a
reservoir e.g. a geothermal reservoir
and and then we have the
natural
seismicity here where, like in
Istanbul, we try to understand the processes
exactly and why are we doing this
now on different scales from
very small to large  medium-sized to large and
that is placed here so
the very small earthquakes are plotted here
and
here is information about
what characterizes them so
I have already shown you the very small magnitudes
but that also means they
only have very small rupture lengths i.e.
millimeters and  take place on small
areas and if we then
go into the induced salmicity, so to speak, a lot of geothermal projects
or here in the mines there are larger
processes on larger fracture surfaces and
then up here the natural earthquakes
on very large fracture surfaces as Marco
has already explained, then we see  They
all fall on a line and that means
they have things in common and these are
things that apply across the scales
and we are now trying to
learn more and more from the small ones where we can observe a lot
for the next scale and then later  To be able to understand the
processes on a very large scale,
right here I'll just show
what is done in the laboratory. You prepare
a sample here, this is a sample
that is 10 x 5 cm in size, a cylinder
and here is a fracture surface on it that
will either  sawn in or you
already have a rock where a fracture surface
exists, then it goes into an apparatus like this
and
measurements are applied everywhere around it
so that we can see what is happening from all sides
and then this whole
apparatus goes into a large press that is
in place  Potzdam with us and there it is
pressed together and the great thing is
we can observe it from all sides
and we can also
control exactly what should happen, should
the sample be dry or should
it be wet, should we
press it quickly or should we press it slowly  we
press on it very hard or with
little force and we can control all of these things
in the laboratory and
that gives us advantages. We
can then see where the
earthquakes occur, so that's
a cross section of this fracture surface, so to speak,
we see them  The smallest weaves appear
on the fracture surface. We can see that
over time our
sample deforms, so it is compressed,
then there is a fracture, then it is
compressed again, then there is the
next fracture, which is always
these, so there is an
offset, so to speak  This fracture surface
and we can observe when
the earthquakes occur, we have earthquakes that
occur before this offset, then we have
several larger events that characterize this
offset, so to speak,
and we also have
aftershocks and if you
look at when do most of them occur?
you can see that it
's actually this pink curve down here, you can
actually see that the aftershocks here
always create such a peak and
exactly and that helps us with
all the data that we generate that
we can feed into computers
with machines machine learning
try to understand what is happening
and here I just want to
say it briefly, so my colleagues here this is
Sadeek, he
looked at what influences could
have and with that he identified 47 characteristics
that
could lead to this  small webs
occur and then he weighted them
and looked, yes, okay, we
applied 47 but which of them are
really important and then he
found that practically seven
of these features are the
most important and that means you can
reproduce these curves quite well
So the sample
is always loaded, then there is an offset,
lots of earthquakes occur and then it starts all over
again, so the
sample is charged until
a certain amount of energy
has accumulated again, so to speak, and then there is
another fracture offset, but what do I do
with that?  I want to say, even in the laboratory, it's
not easy, it took a long time, um,
now it's so to speak that we
can do it with machine learning,
but it's still complicated. 47
parameters is a lot, um, exactly
if we now go to the next scale
now into the mine,
I'll just show it up here, that
's what I've been working on, it's
so, um, practical, it's two
tunnels that lead to a
rock volume that has this or that exact
area, it's 40 x 60 m, so we're like this
now, so to speak  on the ten meter
scale where we do something we can
walk there so we have access through the tunnels
so to speak and then we
drill and with these drill holes
we go into this volume so to speak in order to be able to
observe there too, we
always want to use our
observation sensors  around
because then we can really gain the most
information and that
's similar to in the laboratory but of course
not quite as good but we also have more
realistic conditions that apply to this
rock volume
so there are also a lot of
things that we don't know
but we
have a certain degree of control when we
carry out our experiments there,
this is the project that I
carried out, so here are the
two tunnels that you run through,
then we drilled all these yellow
drill holes to
install sensors, we have this  green
borehole drilled to understand how
the river works, the hydraulics,
and then we
drilled this long blue borehole here and
injected water into the rock and the background is
of course geothermal energy, the water
should seep through the rock,
heat up and  We want to use the warm water
and,
um, exactly what did we see? So
we always
did the same thing at each of these blue places that are marked here and at this point
we saw a lot of the smallest earthquakes,
so acoustic emissions and in
this area  nothing and
um we can learn from that
so um in the laboratory you would
n't be able to observe this range but we
learned different scenarios here so to speak so here the rock was very
intact we created a lot of earthquakes
because the water went into the rock so to speak  There
were problems back here, the water
just ran away like the drain in
the bathtub. We basically
opened the stopper and the water
ran away and probably
came out again somewhere in the tunnel,
but we didn't always
see that, and in some cases we did  seen
but not always um
exactly and now I wanted to show you here
again um so how did we
pump the water in, so to speak, we
first turned on the water with a very small bit, so to speak,
not much happened, there is
a small one every now and then  Earthquakes occurred
but not much and then we
turned it up a little bit more and
then we always turned it up a little bit to
a little bit to a
little bit to that it fluctuated nicely back and
forth and you can see here
the small earthquakes that do the
same thing  sometimes more sometimes less so always
here when we turned down
the water a little bit so to speak there
were fewer earthquakes
then we
turned it up a little again again more earthquakes that
means we managed
to control the earthquakes here too we have
them on as it were  and switched off and
that's exactly what it is,
in this case it's related to the pressure,
that's this curve here that
falls and that's exactly how
the earthquakes fall and those are
processes that we can then understand,
so that e.g  here is controlled by this
water pressure
right here is a big
project that
took place in Helsinki in the last few years,
a 6 km deep borehole was
drilled under Helsinki and there they
also pressed water into the borehole like we did
The earthquakes just occurred
and the important thing here is that you
saw at the beginning, so you first
pumped in down here and then you
saw, okay, we pump water in at a
certain m rate and in a certain
volume and we see earthquakes occur
and  that was this curve and it
roughly showed that it was pretty much a
balance so a pretty balanced
behavior and then you started
pumping faster and you
saw okay suddenly we get a
little bit so we get a lot more
earthquakes that's bad because they
The city of Helsinki has said you
can work until a
magnitude 2 occurs when people
feel magnitude 2 and if
people feel it then we don't want
you to continue, that is, at
magnitude 2 we have the red
light here  The project would have had to be
ended and now
there was a fear that
a lot more salmicity would occur and that this would mean that
this project would
not be able to continue and that's why
they did the following: they simply stopped at
night and pumped during the day
and took a break at night for
12 hours and pumped again the next day
and took a break again at night
and that's what you had, so to speak, you
built in rest phases for the system
and then you saw, okay, it changes
what we're going again from this
steep  Line that probably
means that bigger earthquakes
might happen back into
a flatter line and that's how you
managed to get the earthquakes to have the
greatest magnitude, I think a 1.5,
that's acceptable, that's generally
not felt and that's how you can do it  We were just
running the geothermal energy project and that was
a very important process so that we
can control how we pump the water into the ground, so to speak,
how strong the earthquake activity is and
we want to ensure that we
can use the warm water without
earthquakes occurring  just disturb
no and that was a very important success
so for the first time that
you could control it like that
and now I come back to
our
research point of view KTB continental
deep drilling in the upper fold
so that's down here we're here here
so here  In north-eastern
Bavaria and at this location,
research has been carried out for 30 years
and we have now gone there again
and decided that
we want to continue doing geothermal energy research
and have now started a new project,
so to speak. Why did they
choose this location? I have it here
Here's a map showing the drilling rig and here
it's in this gray zone.
That's called the ZEV and the important reason
why you chose that is that the
rocks come from a great depth.
That's what you can see here. These are the gray
stones  They were in a lot of places, so they
experienced very high pressure, that
is, the goods were at a very great depth and they were
so they experienced much more pressure
than all the rocks that
were around and why was that like that?
300 million years ago they were there  two
continental plates collided with each other
and a mountain range was formed and
this mountain range practically
pushed itself up along a fault and
at some point the mountain range was as high as
the Himalayas and then came wind and
weather and rain and more and more stones
rolled down the slope, so to speak
Nowadays we do
n't see any of it anymore,
but this mountain root is
still there and there are a lot of disturbances,
big disturbances and
we know so much about this location that we are
now hoping that we can
manage it there too  To control processes in the ground
and to control the earthquakes, that's
exactly what it looks like
here. We have these two large
fault systems through which the
borehole was sunk and we not
only have a borehole that is 9 km deep, but
we also have  Shown here in white,
I have a 4 km deep 4 km
deep borehole and both boreholes
penetrate this area that
is interesting for geothermal energy between 100
and 200° right here and at this
location we want to try whether
it can also be used for
heat generation and  why are we doing that
here? So you see the KDW liir here and
the rocks at a depth of 3 km are
very similar in most of Germany,
which means we hope that if we
understand this at the KTB that we can
really apply it in Germany too
and  Exactly and that we
can establish geothermal energy better, at least in this area. Exactly why are we doing our
experiment now at the KTB? It has
to do with these two boreholes. The one
borehole that you can now see here from the
side is not quite straight
runs like this and down here we want to
pump the water in and
we use the other hole to
bring our measuring instruments there and we
are then only 250 m or something away from it
and we can see exactly
what is happening, we can observe very closely
and that's it again
Kind of like in a mine, so we have
the opportunity to
listen better than when we're just sitting on the surface, so to speak,
and when we're on the
surface we're always at least 4
kilometers away and we want to
get as close as possible in order to be able to hear better,
of course  We also have something on the
surface that's our
network here, what it looks like here in the
middle is the hole, so we
also listen from above, but the
crucial thing is that we
manage to
look and listen from the side, so to speak  happened exactly
and this is a picture from this
morning my colleagues are there on site
um I just wanted to show here
what is necessary for this so here
is our drilling site um a very large
crane they are here um
last week before last they are here  Over 12
truckloads of all
these things that we need in order to be able to
research things in 4 km areas have been carted in
and I'm going to take a
closer look here and there are a
lot of people on site who are working on it day and
night  We
practically
manage to
carry out our experiments at a depth of 4 km to understand them and
precisely characterize the processes that take place there and
learn from them
how we can control the whole thing
and I would like to thank you very much for
listening and I look forward to it  If you have
any
questions [applause] it's great that you've
held out for so long. We've now brought two things with you for
those who have been patient for so long.
years ago it looks like a colleague asks
From one of
these two deep boreholes
we can see what it
looks like, it
's about as salty as
Baltic Sea water and Marco says that there
are a lot of heavy metals in it too, so it's better
not to drink, it's better not to drink, yes,
but you're welcome to look and Marco also has
one  There is a stone in it, yes, we can
also let it go through. This is a
rock sample. This is exactly the type
of rock sample that we then
put under tension in the laboratory. This is
first sawed out and drilled and so on.
Then we stick perzo crystals
on it. These are, so to speak, laborismometers,
laboratory microphones  then it goes into
a jacket and then it goes into a
large pressure chamber and then we can
put as much tension on it as,
I don't know, 40,000 trucks so we can
simulate processes like at a depth of 8 to 10 km
and we then put them under
pressure and then  It just starts
to crackle at some point and usually before
the thing breaks and that's what
gives us hope that this happens in nature, but
we ca
n't measure it so well because we
're always further away, but that's why we have it
explained that's why we have holes to
get to poets and so on, that's
our approach to fight our way forward bit by bit,
yes exactly and there's a
question,
I'm on the wrong foot, I
think it's a Benheim sandstone, no,
it's
granite, I have to pass  I'm
looking at granite, but at least there's
more than I
know, so
I'd like to let it go. I think the ones that were here at the beginning
or were already here are cross-
scale processes. That's where I got stuck, but I
think we've now
understood something like that, cross-scale, about millimeters
scale to one meter to tens of meters
to kilometers but deformation processes
what what happens there
deformation basically what is
compressed and breaks it
deforms it changes its
shape exactly I
just made a press release about um
also about the georeal experiment and
Mar said like a crumple zone in the
underground it's actually this
mountain root so for those who don't
know these plates move about
as fast as our
fingernails grow yes that's the
speed at which the earth's plates
move when they
move away from each other is not  so bad but
if they move towards each other
over 250 years then there is AR zone and
then at some point there is a fracture zone yes there
is a second aspect i.e.
deformation on the one hand as Carolin said
the deformation of the rock volume
but on the other hand the deformation on the
fault so on  the plate boundaries and
it is not always the same, there is
seismic deformation, that is, if it
is screwed up and then suddenly tears, then
energy is released, then there are
elastic waves and those are
the problem, but there is also
aseismic deformation like we saw
before Istanbul  We see that
the plates are creeping and
we can now also
measure the creeping in the laboratory through the
measuring strip and so on and this
interaction is very
crucial in order to ultimately
understand the earthquake machine better,
so seismic and interseismic
aseismic all of this  to understand and
measure that is very crucial for us do you
still have questions to understand but
then you have to make yourself clear
because the headlights are very dazzling here
yes microphone microphone then
people can hear it better otherwise I have to repeat the
question
thank you so it would be theoretical  It's possible for
an earthquake like in Istanbul, for example,
that will happen at some point where you don't know
when to trigger it somehow or
to trigger it partially so that you
could prepare, even if the effects
are bad, but
still a good question. In theory, it's
only possible  Nowadays we don't have
nearly enough knowledge about the
processes in detail that we can say,
oh, let's pump a little water in there,
lubricant so that we can
trigger an earthquake of a million magnitude. We
would like that, that's theoretically
possible, but the risk is too great that
we can't  If we were to generate a magnitude 1 quake a million times
then the energy would be
gone, but we
would trigger a big one, which is why we would
never do that in front of
Istanbul. A colleague of ours from Stanford
who led the project on the St
Andreas Fault is also
asked about it  He always
said back then that I would like to pump water in there,
but only when I was retired, so
no one lived there.
Theoretically, we could have done it and that is
also our goal. We want to
carry out controlled earthquake experiments. We are
currently doing so internationally with some
colleagues  to form a group and
set up an observatory at hotspots
and we would also like to
do controlled earthquake experiments. The problem
is, for understandable reasons, there
is no acceptance because nothing can
happen. There are considerations about doing this in the
desert of Nevada or on the
seabed somewhere  spreading zones are where
the plates move apart, it
's more difficult again because there's
still 2-3 km of water above it. We want it to be
considered, but there's
still a long way to go to
really control something like that because it has to
be controlled  It should never get out of
control.
By the way, I was asked the same thing about
the volcano, whether you
could drill into it and
then relieve the pressure, so to speak, and
the answer is something like that: yes, in
theory you can do something about it,
but in practice it works
not
I would like to go back to geothermal energy
geothermal energy everyone knows what
geothermal energy is yes or is there W yes
nod with the children that's below us
it's hot yes in the deep underground 100
200 500 m it gets warmer and warmer when you
come down and then  If you put
a pipe in and pull water out,
you always have warm water, it's
actually quite cool or warm, yes, but
there are problems with geothermal
energy, an induced earthquake. Can you briefly
say injection, there's a bad
word called fracking, yes, how is
it connected?  Do you do the same thing
or is it just
similar?
Geothermal energy is about
getting the water warm
and you have the rock and
one way is to break it up, that's
fracking, you create a
flow path for the rock, so to speak  The other
way is you use flow paths that
are already there, they won't be broken up,
you just put a little pressure on it
so that the water actually
goes through and that's this injection
stimulation, that's why we
chose this location where we already
know that everything down there is shattered
An entire mountain range has
been pushed up in the ground. There are a lot of
flow paths. We also know that because we were
able to get this fluid sample out there. Water had been pulled out of the ground at that location for
over a year.
It was 40° warm and you have it
20,000 cubic meters pumped out, that's
42 swimming pool loads full, so a
lot but that's not enough, it
's not economical enough for the
next city that's there to be
able to use it day and night and that's why
we have to add the water,
we have to add the water  put in
the water has to seep through and then
we pump it out again and this
seep through that is practically what
we are trying to create and
unfortunately there is seismicity induced
seismicity because the water
sometimes seeps in then there is like a
plug or a flop and that  has to
break so that the water can continue and
these are small induced earthquakes, so
they are caused by us because we
put pressure on the system
before there was no pressure on it or or a
certain background pressure but we
just put more on it so that we can
make this path accessible  It really
becomes like a heating system that
once it flows completely through and
then we can pump it out again because
we can't just pull it out, then
other things happen, so that's what
you see in the geothermal fields, they
started there 30-40 years ago, just
the warm  Taking water out and
at some point the earth starts to sink
because you
have just removed so many large amounts of water, you have
to give it in too, so you have to give
the system the opportunity to
recharge and let the water
circulate through again, so to speak, which is
exactly why we're not just allowed to go out
Well, we also have to initiate the water
so that it
works, yes, and if you don't
know it yet, in Pozdam we have just
accompanied the first geothermal drilling,
which has been highly successful,
about a kilometer deep and has reached 40 - 50 °C
hot water and
a power plant is now being built there  built and there will be
more drilling soon
and we are
also planning in the area around Berlin and in
Berlin itself you can try to
use geothermal energy. There are still
questions. WD might like to
take up the word fracking again
and do it in a broader context  So
fracking is of course a
burnt word for various
reasons, it is always important to
include the processes involved and
above all it is important to put it in perspective,
it is a nimbi phenomenon not
in my backyard, of course electricity is good but it has
to be from the socket  come and not
with me there has been
experience in coal mining for centuries that
the earth there would shake from time to time then
there would be a few cracks and then
the homeowners
were also compensated and of course also participated
because they had jobs, this
discussion is difficult  At
the KDB we have a very high level of
acceptance from the local population, we have
stimulated there several times, we have
pumped in water, we have
monitored and we have an
extensive
public relations concept there and we
have the acceptance, which is why this is
a very important blueprint for us
The experiment that is
starting next week is to present the topic of geothermal energy in a
positive way to the public.
The alternative is
of course that we continue to have to buy oil and
natural gas from Arabia or Russia or
somewhere else. Of course, no one wants that,
so they have their own domestic energy
Advantages back there is another question,
come with the
microphone, thank you, and in the
first lecture you said that it was about
putting certain measuring graphs into the earth and then hoping to be
able to measure it before, during and after the earthquakes  Are you
also sure that these measuring devices
can measure the before, during and after and not
break down somehow or something like that? We are very
sure because the safest place in an
earthquake is to be underground, for
example in the in the  in mines or something like that, the
seiometers, so we first
sunk the drilling, then we
carried out a few investigations, then
we used the measuring devices and
then we cemented the whole drilling, which is
why we do this so that the sensors
are well connected to the subsoil
and and if possible  measure good ground movement
because all we measure is
the ground movement, which means they are
basically one with the ground and in
an earthquake like this we of course have
the rupture where a lot of things break, that is at
the plate boundary and the seismic
waves are the problem  They
then run to the surface to static
areas and so on,
but they are elastic waves, which means that
something runs through like water in the
bathtub, like a wave when you
throw a stone in, but afterwards
everything is calm again and then everything is as it was
before
clipped or or
the measurements this movement and
then continue to work and that during and after
yes, I said that so easily,
for us it is of course primarily about
measuring for the Istanbul area beforehand
so that we can try to understand
what is happening now and when  But of
course we exchange our
measurement results and knowledge with
colleagues around the world who
also measure on other fault zones and that's
why the during and after is
important in order to then transfer the findings
to cities like Kito, the
earthquake zones are Teran San Francisco
Los Angeles Tokyo and  so on because
the physics in the subsurface is
the same everywhere, it is the same in the laboratory
as at plate boundaries and on
all continents and that is what
motivates us or
makes us positive that we can move a little further
into the next one
We haven't
agreed on it for years, but I still have to ask the question
because I'm
asked the same question again and again. There are people who
say yes, why are you doing so much
electronic and mechanical
stuff? All you have to do is look at the
animals feeling it, but then they run
away  Animals and earthquakes Can you
say a word about it? Yes, I can, so it's
about the topic of foreshocks.
So ultimately it's just about whether
you
have reproducible signs that something is happening before an earthquake.
Personally, it doesn't matter to me whether the
foreshocks are outgassing or  Whether it's
roosters, crows or cows
running away, the reports come up again and
again, unfortunately after earthquakes, usually
not before earthquakes,
so it's difficult, what we
need, so the experiments that we
carry out are carried out, are
reproducible and we do that so often
until we say yes, that is significant, that
is produced but we can use that
to then take the most important step at some point to
tell the authorities on site here you have a
method so that you can issue a warning
because we do not issue a
warning that is  a highly complex
process a BEV
to prepare a city for such an earthquake mm the
problem with animal behavior is that it
occurs again and again but is usually only
reported afterwards and then
not in advance
[music]
say it is reliable enough there is
a second example  game of
animal behavior which is very
interesting though, it has nothing
to do with earthquakes but with tsunamis during
the Sumatra explosion in 2004 there was the
devastating tsunami and almost
no mammals died there, why did they
run up the mountain after the earthquake but before the tsunami? something like that
like an evolutionary developed tsunami
early delusion system so it has nothing
to do with earthquake forecasters but the
knowledge from a long process
unconsciously if the earth shakes
tsunamis could come then run up the mountain there
is something like that and it has also been
proven but it remains a difficult
field so it remains a difficult one  The key word is
reproducibility, quite simply, that you
really need the results to be
reliable and say the
same thing over and over again and you don't have that with the animals.
So here's another question.
First of all, thank you for the
information. I have a question about
the earthquake  Istanbul so there are
speculations as to which regions in
Turkey apart from Istanbul could be
severely affected by this earthquake
B also have a
look so Istanbul is a
hotspot because there is this big biggest
city there and also the surrounding area with 20
million people is a miracle there are other
areas  Also in the area in the east-
southeast that was now affected,
we are sure that sooner or
later there will be further large earthquakes there,
not in the place where
the earthquake was, the energy is gone there
and is now slowly being recharged again
over 100 150  Years but for example also the
entire western Turkey I have
exactly if we can do it I can
turn back but I can't get any further
right now okay the entire western Turkey
on the Egyptian Aegean coast is being
pulled apart in a north-south direction
like chewing gum it's because
Crete in the south is to the south  pulls and the
crust pulls apart. There are
a lot of east-west facing
earthquake zones, which are also a big
problem and in the summer there are
millions of people on vacation there. Lying on the
beach. Earthquakes or tsunamis are an
issue in the entire Mediterranean region, but that's
particularly the case and that's where we're stuck
Let's hang on the slide so it was
the map where the whole of Turkey
was shown and large areas were red, these
are the areas where there
are either plate boundaries or where, let's say,
this kaugumi process is going on
and these were large areas in
Turkey is really a
hotspot for earthquakes, similar to or
probably even more so than
Greece or Italy, but there are
currently cross-border
initiatives there to
set up a tsunami early warning system, because a
tsunami is of course a big
issue there, so unfortunately I'm getting war  I don't have the map,
but Marco explained it very
well. I don't know whether you were me
or my colleague because I also
asked why people are so
stupid and always settle exactly
where it is. They could
live somewhere else  where it is quieter, yes, and
then the scientist explained to me
at these
borders rivers have often
formed there are transport routes, so
for thousands of years they have
actually been
art regions for trade routes for
cities and in this respect it has simply been
populated for thousands of years and you
can  Since you can't just build a city somewhere
else, that's
exactly what the map was about, so
I've just explained everything and it's
relatively easy to read,
I think there's another
question. It could also be that
climate change is leading to other
regions on earth
Earthquake hotspots,
for example, it's hard to say, we know
that areas where the glaciers
are melting away, that
earthquakes are occurring more frequently there, because this
load that the ice has practically represented for decades, centuries,
thousands of years
is then simply gone and then that leads to
relief  of the ground and therefore also
significant earthquakes, so
I wouldn't rule it out,
but we don't know exactly that still needs to
be researched really well. There was
a lake in Uta hundreds of years ago
and due to a climatic
event, this lake is practically empty  ran
within a very short time and that
also led to a lot of
earthquakes occurring there, which means that all of
these significant changes were
also mentioned in the example of Keuner, where
the water
changes dramatically on a regular basis due to this strong monsoon,
anything can cause earthquakes, but
these earthquakes  well, depending on the size of the
change, that also corresponds to the
size of the earthquake, so in order for the really
significant, very large earthquake to
become a really significant one, a lot has to
change, so it will
be a gradual process. I would
say that there will definitely
be smaller earthquakes as a result
Maybe two more
comments will be triggered, completely correct, we do
n't have the time to wait until the
sea level rises and then
look at it, yes it happens or it doesn't happen,
but again that's another reason
why we can bring it into the laboratory and do it there
We can simulate these processes
or
imitate them experimentally,
but there is an analogue from
the last 10,000 years,
namely the time since the last
ice age. There was a huge ice sheet in Scandinavia, for example,
which
melted away and then as a result
Scandinavia rose  Today you can still
measure very slowly, which has led
to earthquakes due to these unloaded processes,
the blades
are still there, even under
northern Germany at a depth of 25 km, small
clicker events that no one notices,
but there were earthquakes and there are
actually research projects in there
in Sweden, for example, where a fault like this
is supposed to be drilled into and you can see that
this can happen and these are the
areas that are not red on the world map
because no earthquakes have occurred there in the last few
hundred years.
Maybe you can do
that too  In addition, there
are a lot of big earthquakes in Antarctica on a
regular basis and I
think that would be the place where you would have to look,
where you would simply expect the biggest
changes and that's where
researchers do that, that's why there are
the stations there and exactly that  It's
probably already happening, so
maybe not necessarily with the focus now,
but it's definitely being
investigated and researched there and we're
now getting down to business, but
in Scandinavia there are ports where it
looks like the sea level is
falling because the land is moving faster  rises
as the sea level rises, so that
creates some really crazy effects
and for that you need
geosciences that say wait a
minute, it's not the ocean level that's sinking,
but the land is rising and we
also know why
you don't have ebb and flow too
what has been proven in the Marmar Sea yes we
have um
I said that we are trying
to develop something like a fever curve
to see whether the danger is
greater or smaller and as a
sub-project a colleague of ours took
a look at what effect a
change in the water level has  Marmar
Sea and in this case
the strongest changes are actually caused by storms of up to
about 0.8 m up and down and what
we do using artificial
intelligence and we are always very,
very careful because we don't use it as a
black box where we can
prove it  Through the use of
AI,
whenever the sea level
was at its highest and then began to
fall, we had slightly more
small earthquakes and that indicates
that the crust there is critically stressed
and even a small
change is a small change 0  .8 m
are enough to influence the breathing of the crust, so to speak,
and that is,
for example, an input parameter that whenever
the sea level or the
water level in the Marmar Sea
reaches a maximum, the risk of
an earthquake is perhaps a little
greater and if we have several  If we
have such parameters and put them all
together and resources then we are
optimistic that at some point we will be able to provide the
authorities with important
information,
but that is still ongoing research at the moment
and we are not yet
ready to release it because it is
doesn't work well enough yet because
it's complex, maybe just as
an addition. In the
preliminary discussion we thought about how we could
illustrate these processes and
we thought about the best way to
imagine it is how B the
balloon is inflated, the
balloon can  burst and every little
change puts a little more air
in or maybe lets a
little bit of air out but we just do
n't know when the balloon will burst because
we don't know how much it is
inflated and that's why it's just
exactly it's difficult, no, a
small one  Blower can be enough, it can
release it but it doesn't have to and it
can go well a hundred times so to speak and
it won't be released and the last
little blower is then released. Jaolin
wanted to take balloons with me but I
'm so scared and said I wo
n't let any balloons open here  I'm so scared
until it bursts so you do
n't have mine with you, she even has
some with you so when I'm gone then
you can
blow up the balloon  come
later and then you
both get the balloon yes you have a
lot of z very
good does anyone still have
questions to ask yes then they
ask but the question is so they
have a tipping point now mentioned
a theoretically possible
tipping point yes that it  An earthquake
can occur with a small
change in pressure
then the
relaxation tensions the forces so
that they break the K but
they didn't answer the question about
other tipping points or if
or what to say here you do so
we only talked about earthquakes today
Tipping point would now have to
look up the strict definition means that
due to a small change in the
system the system becomes unstable,
so it is comparable.
In seismology we don't talk about
tipping points but it is actually a
good comparison because at some point
the little puff or that is enough  small piece of
shift and then big event and
then the system becomes unstable and then
all the energy that is
stored there or large that is stored is released
so it's already a comparison um
yes but it stays that way we have to get going
we have to go down we have to see what
happens on site because we
have no view of the system, in contrast
to the climate tipping points, for example.
I have a question about what happens to the
continental plates if there is just a
small space earthquake, for example
if there is just a small space earthquake, it's
okay, so the plates are pushing
continuously either towards each other
or away from each other depending on
which area you are in and
these earthquakes happen and we know
that sometimes there can be
earthquakes beforehand and then the
earthquake is followed by a larger earthquake, so the
earthquakes can happen  influence each other
exactly but essentially
this general
movement towards or
away from each other influences the earthquakes exactly from
pressure relief also spoken about
the charging and relief or and
that is that is so to speak this this
movement maybe you can
say a short sentence about it  say as you
imagine it, yes, is that in the
direction of the question or or I
still think I didn't
understand enough what was behind the question, I'd
like to ask again, no
problem like it is with the
continental plates during a space earthquake
what do you mean by space earthquakes they
then move a little further
so hit a small
earthquake within a plate somewhere
what happens there so the
continental plate notices the good question can
I go back to or I do
n't know if you were there I asked earlier  The
Richter scale is shown, which puts the small
and large earthquakes in relation
and you can show this on a
number line, but the
difference is huge, which means that a
small
earthquake makes almost no contribution to
releasing the energy that is in the underground
because a
magnitude catches  let's think of a
magnitude F earthquake, which is an earthquake that
you can easily notice but where
the houses don't collapse, it has as much
energy as a magnitude 30, a 4 quake has as
much as a magnitude 900, a 3 quake has as
much as a magnitude 27,000, a Z quake  That
means the little clicky quakes that
produce energy but only fractions
of what is stored in the system.
That means to answer the question,
the little ones don't make a difference
then ask why why
are
volcanoes so
stoney? So a volcano forms in a
volcano because something
melts from below  Rock
comes up and when the rock is the
molten rock that we call lava
when it comes out then it cools down and
then solid rocks form from this
molten rock and
they are all piled on top of each other
and that's how we get a volcanic mountain and that's
why we have there  a lot of rock
because it came out of the ground and
cooled down but it's a very good question, there
's another
yes, so the places that
are currently geologically inactive can be active later
and if so, is there an
example like this on
Earth  In terms of tectonics,
the answer is no because
plate tectonics are processes that
are driven by huge
environmental pumps in the subsurface, the
continents go along with this movement and
this movement is stable, according to everything we
know about
decades, we know
about centuries, probably
thousands of years or
decades  Maybe there is a
small variation every now and then, but the
plate displacement is
essentially only approximately stable, which is good
because the charging process is constant, which
means the energy
increases linearly, then an earthquake occurs, then
charging occurs again,
um, if the question is about whether that
Unfortunately, it doesn't help to estimate earthquakes anywhere on earth because
there
is energy stored far away from these red zones in the KR in the
earth's crust due to earlier
tectonic processes, so we don't know
what's happening because
nothing shifts there anymore or it
only shifts very, very
slowly but if something
shifts very, very slowly then it can still
lead to earthquakes occurring over longer periods of time.
new Madrid is a be
in the USA there was a magnitude 7 ebb in
the middle of the plate where there is no
displacement and areas like that
There are probably also
many other places in India. There was
an earthquake in Bui in 2001. Earthquake in the city of
Bui in 2001. Magnitude just below A. There was
previously a white spot on our
hazard map because earthquakes
only occur there every 1000 or 2000 years.
Christchurch in New Zealand was
one  In a very prominent example, you can
perhaps say something else called
blind if you don't even know that there
are critically charged faults below,
so there will also be earthquakes in the future in
places where we don't even suspect it,
that's simply because the
earthquake cycle has very different
time periods  So it can cover around 250
years, which is a fast cycle,
I would say like on the North Anatolian
fault or in New Zealand
in the fault that I
examined there, the Alpine fault,
but there are also cycles that are much, much,
much longer  I
think we have the best record
from the Dead Sea, from
Jordan because the cycle is
significantly longer at least twice as
long and I say we have
information about it happening three four
five times, um but if we don't have
anything  Know about a place just because
we don't see any earthquakes does
n't mean that there were never earthquakes, that's
the problem, that's why there are these
white spots, we just
don't know for sure, we have Marco
showed the map of Germany, there were
these white balls or  white
circles on it uh we have a
scientist with us uh he
really looked at history books because
the problem is we have had
measuring devices for maybe 100 years but
what do I have before that I only have
reports from some church books that
say then in the neighboring town there is the
church tower  collapsed or did it
all break down because God's punishment
whatever and then you could tell the
year and he really took the
trouble to
compare everything and then created a catalog
and only from such
historical records and
comparison, yes  Now a church
collapsed and how many houses were there
and so ah that would
probably have been magnitude 5
or something like that. Only from that do
we actually know what
happened centuries or millennia ago and exactly
this entire worldwide
zone is exactly the same
We only know that because there
was an earthquake at the times we know, but if we don't
know it, there could still be an earthquake. Good
point, that's e.g.  large un between dead
sea disturbance Jordan Turkey long settlement
history good historical
record that goes back a long time s
Andreas Fault let's say more
than 300 years ago hardly any information because
the indigenous Indian population
did not make any records that we
could use, which means that they know about the
historical settlement there  means everything
that happened 100 years ago before there were
seismometers, very very little there
is a really cool story,
you can google it
in the north of San Andreas, near
Seattle, there is also a
zone where you never knew whether it was so
seismically active  in ancient times and there
was a so-called
wise man, an unknown
tsunami that the Japanese didn't know about in
1599 or 16 or something where a
tsunami simply came without an
earthquake where a lot of Japan was destroyed on the coast
and then they have it with
oral traditions  compared to
North American natives who
said so and so
many generations ago the earth trembled strongly in our country
and there was
obviously such a strong earthquake on
the American west coast that the
wave swept all the way to Japan and then
you could have both events
without it  The Japanese have written
records for many, many
centuries but the
North American inhabitants
don't.
You have a question, you
can also ask me and then
I'll say it
further.
I have a very difficult question as to why the
animals
are extinct. Yes, that's also
geoscience. There are always
great accidents  Given that
an asteroid fell onto the earth and
then the dinosaurs died out, and
there were earthquakes and
volcanic eruptions everywhere and then the sea
became very acidic because so much sulfur rock was hit and
then the poor sea snails
and mussels could no longer
form lime shells  and then the fish
starved and then 70% of all animals
died out and something like that happens every now and then
but the good news is
every 50 to 100 million years,
perhaps for a very long
time, no ha moreil
planet exactly one planet, so almost a
planet was one  Asteroid yes, but it comes
very
close,
as well as
geopalontological volcanological
geothermal
questions then I would like to thank you very
much and thank you both very much
[applause].